vp kamala harris passing the buck on her
border czar responsibilities
fox news contributor laura trump joins
us now laura good morning thank you for
taking time on friday
what is with the vice president blaming
congress for the crisis at the border
uh well good morning guys look she
blames everybody basically but herself
for for so many things she's taking zero
responsibility here she is the borders
are by the way we are coming up in march
on the one year anniversary
of her being named the borders are she
has gone down to the southern border one
time she didn't even go to the rio
grande valley where the real issue is
she went down to guatemala one time and
was embarrassed by the guatemalan
president who even said hey you aren't
doing the right thing here i mean i
could even see that even though i'm not
in the united states and then she went
on telemundo here and and said this was
the top priority of the administration
that is one of the things that she said
so let me translate that for every
american
the biden harris administration says
that they are prioritizing illegal
immigrants over american citizens if
this is their top priority amnesty for
what we know they wanted 11 million
people a year ago now two million people
we know of have come in the country over
the past year um and that is a lot of
people to just grant citizenship to um
all of a sudden so look the this is
nothing surprising for anyone kamala
harris has taken zero responsibility for
anything since she was named vice
president but it is concerning because
absolutely nothing is being done on our
southern border and it is still a crisis
it was a crisis a year ago that's why
she was named borders are it is a crisis
today and nothing has changed yeah and
as she's fielding questions about her
role as
the borders are addressing the root
causes
another staffer from her office
just left this time her chief
speechwriter bringing the total to eight
why is this happening
well guess you know when a ship is
sinking people want to jump off when
that ship is on fire and sinking which
seems to be the case with this entire
administration people want to get away
from that i think it's pretty clear you
look at the poll numbers you look at you
know what these two joe biden and kamala
harris have done since they took office
people can see the writing on the wall
no staffer wants to be associated
with a failed presidency with a failed
vice presidency and have their name on
that so i assume that they are jumping
ship because what else would you do when
that ship is going down there are a lot
of reports obviously that kamala harris
isn't great to work for it seems like
she wants the job without doing any of
the work to have that job so i imagine
that this must be a very challenging
environment to work in
but look you can't blame people if
things feel like they're going poorly
and you are not happy in your role there
i assume people want to leave
let me just in the last 25 seconds or so
we have laura askew do you think that
this issue of the border is going to
cost democrats in november
oh absolutely look anybody with their
eyes open in this country can see this
as a problem they have not addressed it
in any way and in fact they're actually
ushering more people in and encouraging
more people all across the world to come
to america this is horrible for our
country it's hurting people all across
america it has to stop and yes griff i
think come november the democrats are
going to feel the implications of that's
right border agents are frustrated
they're speaking out and a lot of
american people are as well lara thank
you so much for joining us this morning
happy friday
thanks guys hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now